[Music]
Disney did not miss the opportunity to
announce news about the second season of
Loki at the recent d23 Expo in addition
to the new cast member Jonathan Ki Kwan
who was known as shorty from Indiana
Jones in the Temple of Doom those
present were also treated to a first
trailer the short clip shows the main
character Loki limping down a long
hallway along with unsettling music a
voiceover can be heard in which he says
that he was pulled through time and saw
Terrible Things moreover not only TVA
but the entire universe would be facing
complete destruction after the events of
the first season he and Mobius reunite
however it is obvious that Loki has
definitely ended up in another world
where no one recognizes him in the
meantime Sylvia is seen in a living room
she apparently has not yet found inner
peace after killing he who remains she
also seems to have no memory of Loki so
it is unclear when the two will meet
again recent Edition Jonathan Ki Quan
only shows up in a brief scene where he
looks like a TVA employee According to
some reports the trailer makes a very
creepy impression at times it could even
be mistaken for a horror movie Tom
Hiddleston who was one of the star
guests at the presentation added that
the mainly returning cast will be
exploring a much more dangerous
Multiverse than in the first season
judging by the first trailer description
we are definitely excited to hopefully
see it with our own eyes soon Loki
season 2 will be released on Disney Plus
in 2023
[Music]
thank you